In the last couple of videos,
I had started a cupcake
factory and I was the richest
guy in town and I was doing so
well that it attracted
competition.
And then Imran came
in and he started
his own cupcake factory.
And he took all of my
business and he
ended up charging $2.90.
And, I think, the number I used
in the last video, he
sold 500,000 cupcakes.
And he had this great
return on asset.
I think it was 20%
of something.
He took away all my business
and I got decimated.
I think my cupcakes-- I was
originally charging
something like $3.
And my cupcakes, I only started
selling 250,000 of
them and then my
return on asset
essentially went to zero.
I was kind of break-even.
And at the end of the last
video, not being a great
businessman, I said, oh
well, actually let
me just raise prices.
Because I have this set number
of customers and they like the
way I operate the cash register
a little bit, or
maybe they live a little bit
closer to my cupcake factory,
or my bakery, or whatever
you want to call it.
And so I actually
raised prices.
I cut out a little bit of a
profit, but actually by doing
that, I do lose a couple of
these people because they are
willing to walk a little bit
further for a cupcake.
But I get an OK return.
But this is kind of maximizing
it and then, over time, more
and more people realize that
Imran's charging so much less
for cupcakes.
So actually my revenue stream
starts to decline because
fewer and fewer people
show up.
I say this really isn't a
sustainable situation.
Imran came here.
I think he was he was selling
500,000, right?
He's getting this great
return on asset.
I'm getting this crummy
I'm only making $40,000
a year; he's
making $300,000 a year.
I need to get back at him.
So what I do is, I say, let me
lower the price and, besides
taking some of his business,
there will actually be some
incremental more people in the
town who will actually
start buying it.
So it's not a zero sum game.
A zero sum game means that if I
win, someone else is losing
by that amount.
If I lower prices, I'll take
some business from Imran.
But there will also be people
who were probably eating
something more nutritious than
cupcakes who might now eat
cupcakes to get their daily
requirements of sugar and
trans-fat then, in the case
of my cupcakes, nicotine.
So, let's say, I cut prices
below Imran because I realize
this increase price strategy
was kind of silly.
So I lower my prices to $2.70
and, at $2.70, I'm able to
sell, I don't know,
400,000 cupcakes.
And I took some business
from Imran, right?
I'm not a lot cheaper
than him, but
I'm a good bit cheaper.
So, let's say, I took some
business, so he's only selling
400,000 cupcakes and now, the
aggregate cupcake and--
actually not.
Let's ignore this for a little
bit because now, in this
reality, I'm getting a 15%
return on my asset.
Imran's getting a 7% percent
return on asset.
Let's say there's a third party,
Vikram And he just has
a love for making cupcakes and
he says, well, you know, what
if I could spend my life making
cupcakes and, even if I
just get a 7% return, that's
a pretty good living.
And a 15% return
would be great.
So he also enters the market.
He's kind of a smaller
operator.
He didn't have quite as much so
he puts $500,000 into it.
He has a 400,000 cupcake
per year capacity.
Since there's a smaller
factory , it's
a little less efficient.
It costs them a little bit more
to produce a cupcake.
And he comes in and he says, you
know, my joy in life isn't
so much-- he obviously has to
pay his bills, he likes to be
rich --but he says, he just
derives joy from seeing people
eat cupcakes.
So he undercuts everybody.
And in doing so he just operates
at full capacity.
He operates at 400,000.
He operates at full capacity.
And then he takes business
from these guys.
from me as well.
And then, what's the state of
affairs in our city now?
So my return on asset is 7%.
Imran is essentially
at break-even.
He's making no money.
And then Vikram is making a 12%
return on asset because--
essentially, he undercut
everyone and was able to take
all the volume.
And, if you look at the city
as a whole, that's the
aggregate capacity right here.
And this is the second worksheet
in that-- Let me
tell you where it is again, if
you didn't watch the last
video, is khanacademy.org/
downloads/cupcakes.xls.
But anyway, Vikram had entered
the market, and now I
calculated here aggregate
capacity.
This is the total number of
cupcakes all of the factories
in the market can produce.
This is the aggregate demand.
So 1.1 million cupcakes are
getting sold a year and then
this is the average return
on asset, right?
But in this situation, what
continues to happen?
I have all of this
extra capacity.
Only 32% of my capacity is being
utilized and, obviously,
right now you can say the market
price for cupcakes is
well above the marginal cost
of producing a cupcake.
And Imran's sitting there with
this huge amount of capacity,
and maybe he's the richest guy,
because he has a huge
inheritance from grandma.
And so he says, this is silly.
I'm the biggest guy in town.
I'm the most efficient
guy in town.
I have all the capacity.
I'm the richest guy in town
and I'm making the worst
returns on assets.
So what he says is, you know
what, I'm just going to
undercut everybody.
I'm going to charge
$1.70 per cupcake.
At $1.70 per cupcake, all of a
sudden, there's a whole new
market for people who want
to eat cupcakes.
There's a lot of people who
might have been eating
Twinkies and other things, that
maybe they could get at
$1.80 per Twinkie, and now
cupcakes are the desired
source of food.
So, obviously, aggregate demand
is going to go up and,
let's say, he just sells out.
He just goes and he sells two
million cupcakes a year.
And so he makes a huge
return and he
just kills our business.
So I'm just taking huge losses
and Vikram is taking huge
losses, right?
He's like, you know what, we
have to match his prices.
I sell it at $1.70 and then
Vikram sells at $1.70.
And we said at $1.70, people are
willing to eat two million
cupcakes in a year.
So, let's say, at $1.70 it's
split evenly between-- well
Vikram can only produce
400,000 cupcakes.
So let's say he sells 400,000.
And then the remainder split
between the other two.
So, let's see, 800,000
and 800,000.
And, as you can see here,
there's a general trend that,
as people have extra capacity,
there's almost this incentive
to lower your price relative
to the other person.
Because if you're not using your
capacity, then that's a
cupcake that's not being
made that otherwise
could have been made.
And your cost of producing that
incremental cupcake is a
lot lower, so you're just
like, well, as long as I
charge something more than that,
I'm going to make money
that I otherwise wouldn't
have made.
But when you do that,
you're actually
lowering the market price.
And then all the parties keep
wanting to do that.
And that's why competition
really is good for customers.
And that's why a monopoly
is bad.
If you were a monopoly, if Sal's
Cupcakes were the only
guy in town, he could just
keep his prices high.
And even if his utilization went
down, there would be no
incentive for him
to lower prices.
But in this reality with
competition, there's this huge
incentive that, when you have
extra capacity, especially if
you have a lot of extra
capacity, there's this huge
incentive to lower prices
so that you can
utilize that capacity.
Likewise, if you're running near
full capacity, there's a
huge incentive to
raise prices.
Because if you're at full
capacity, and we saw that in
the last video, when it was
just me, I went to full
capacity and I was able to raise
prices because all that
extra money just goes to me.
But, as you can see, there's a
couple of key learning points
in this set of videos.
When you have huge returns, as
Sal's Cupcakes had in this
video or in this worksheet over
here-- When you have huge
returns, it attracts
competition.
The competition attracts
capacity, right?
We went from aggregate capacity
from one million with
my original factory,
to now 3.4 million.
And then, when you have that
extra capacity, everyone's
incentive is really to lower
prices so that they can try to
grab some of that utilization.
The only way that you could
avoid this is, if Sal, Imran,
and Vikram were to meet in a
room and say, hey guys what
we're doing is silly why don't
we just all agree on a price.
And you might say that's a good
business move and, if you
actually did it, you would
end up in jail.
Well, hopefully you'd be
in jail if you had good
regulators, because that's
called collusion.
You'd be forming a cartel.
You'd be forming a group that
is trying to control prices.
So in a truly competitive
environment, we're not allowed
to communicate and we're not
allowed to tell each other,
hey, why don't we just
set prices at X.
We always have to be competing
with each other and lowering
our prices.
But the general theme here
is, when you're at high
utilization-- the whole reason
why I'm even entering into
this whole spreadsheet and all
of that, is to talk about
inflation in general.
But, in general, prices will
go up when you have high
utilization, right?
If all of us were running
at 100% utilization--
Actually, let's do
that scenario.
Let's say, for whatever reason,
everyone is able to
get cheap loans, and they take
home equity loans, and they
decide to use all of that extra
money that is coming
from their home ATM
to buy cupcakes.
So aggregate demand goes up huge
and all of the cupcakes
in the market get sold out.
So I'm selling a million
cupcakes per year.
Imran is selling two million
And then Vikram is
selling 400.
So we're all tapped out, we're
at 100% capacity utilization.
And then the return on assets
are pretty good.
But we all, as a group, say,
wow, you know, if I'm already
sold out, why don't I just raise
prices because it's not
going to affect demand
so much.
People want cupcakes so badly,
so I could raise prices to $2.
That improves my return
on asset.
Imran's no dummy, so he
does the same thing.
He raises his price to $2.
And let's say people are getting
so much money from
their home equity loans and
they're still willing to buy
the cupcakes from us.
And Vikram does the
same at $2.
And so everyone's return on
asset improves even more and
you can even argue that it would
attract competition.
But I think three players
is good enough.
And let's say it just keeps
happening and I realize that I
can raise my prices all the way
to $3 without affecting my
utilization, without any
impact on demand.
Let's say it has a slight
impact on utilization.
So I'm selling 950,000
cupcakes a year.
He's selling, I don't
know, 1.8 million
cupcakes in a year.
And let's say Vikram
is selling 380,000
cupcakes in a year.
But in general, if you look at
returns in the industry, in
this situation, by raising our
prices, we're getting better
and better returns, right?
More money's coming to
the bottom line.
So, as long as we have a pretty
high utilization-- and
people debate on what is the
level of utilization in lot of
industries where it makes
sense to raise prices.
But, when you're at a relatively
high utilization,
it really pays to increase
your price hurdle.
And on the other side of the
coin, when you have a low
utilization of your asset, even
though it might not be
completely-- well, it is
rational if you're a
competitor.
But when you have very low
utilization, you essentially
want to lower your prices so
that you can utilize your
factory more.
And you can play around with
this and just think about some
scenarios yourself.
And that's the real big take
away I wanted you to get at,
is that high utilization of
anything, of our aggregate
capacity, prices
will increase.
Low utilization, prices
will decrease.
And actually I'll
say two things.
High utilization will allow you
to raise prices and when
you raise price you'll get a
better return on your asset,
and then the other side effect
is, when you have that high
return on asset, you'll also
have more investment going on
to build more capacity.
So aggregate capacity
will go on.
So those are the two side
effects of high utilization.
You have prices increasing and
then you have more capacity or
more investment coming on.
Low utilization, you have kind
of the opposite situation.
No incentive for someone to add
a factory, like we did in
these situations, and there's
every incentive for every
player in the market to the
lower prices because they just
want to use their factories.
Otherwise their factories
just go unutilized.
Anyway, I think I said the
same thing five times in
different ways, but I think
that's your point.
I'll return to the drawing
board, literally, in the next
video and we can proceed with
our discussion of inflation
and deflation.